Hello everybody. Hope that you're good.
Today we are not talking about Bitcoin.
Today we are talking about copper. Yes,
copper. I've said several times this
year that I'm very bullish on this
metal. I've been buying it over the past
two years in a monthly basis. So um now
this year is starting to to pay off all
the all that investment. But what I want
to do with this video is to explain why
I think that cop is still going to go
much higher in 2026 and 2027 and why
practically every single investor should
consider having it in their portfolio.
Of course, you know, all the metals
market is going up. You have gold,
silver, platinum, alltime highs, also
copper. And it's pretty much because you
know the expectations for inflation are
still quite high or governments are very
responsible. They continue printing
money to and that increasing the debt
while devaluating
or fiat currencies. You can see how the
euro the dollar the pound have lost a
lot of power over the last you know say
5 10 years non-stop really and it's
going to continue doing so. So the metal
markets are a great hedge against
inflation. That I would say is the
number one reason why the metal market
is going up. Now also the other thing
about copper is that if you pin these
highs here, this resistance, you can see
how it's been tested one, two, three
times. Okay? Then it broke out. We
didn't get that fast rejection like we
did in all previous times. So when you
start to see that something is changing,
you're starting to see this
consolidation over here. That means that
there is something different than Praise
when I break out. We saw the same with
the Bitcoin dominance in that very tight
range in the weekly time frame. You can
go back and have a look, but pretty much
the same thing. Why also knew at this
point that copper was going to break
out. Now you have it at $12,000
the tone alltime highs. Again, I don't
think it's gonna continue to go much
higher over the next two years. I'm
looking for Okay, and again, maybe this
doesn't happen, but what I'm looking for
is, as you can see, every single time
that price goes up in a very
overextended way, you see some retraces.
Okay, you saw those. So what it could
happen now is that in the worst case
scenario that copper goes back down. I
would expect this previous resistance to
become the new support. You also want to
have the weekly 50 MA coming that way.
Okay, and acting as support. This level
should hold and then price should
continue going up. Okay, I'm expecting
it to go around 17 to $18,000
atone over the next two years. Okay,
2027 target. So, uh, that that's pretty
much to tell you how bullish I'm on
copper. I've been buying it since $8,000
a ton. So, that'll be practically a
atomist 2. All right. Uh, that's what
I'm trying to to achieve and I and I'm
pretty sure I will. Several reasons.
Let's start with them. Is AI. Do you
guys think that AI is a bubble? That's
the first question that you need to
answer in if you want to invest in
copper because it's very linked to it.
You have to to understand that you know
uh for the AI development you need to
build a lot of data centers for that you
need copper is the main thing that you
need you know so personally I do think
that AI is here to stay and it's also
been proved that the biggest bish boys
for AI Michael Buri saying that it was a
bubble it was because at that time he
was in a short in losses and he had to
try to dup the market to get out of his
position.
that's been proved. You can have a look.
Okay. Um I personally think that AI is
here to stay. It continues to grow.
Most companies, most big companies are
adopting AI. So to me it's very clear
that AI is not a bubble. Same as
internet was not a bubble and is here to
stay. So for that we need data centers.
For data centers you need copper. Okay.
More things. What about solar energy or
wind energy? For that you also need
copper.
Now the second reason for me is solar
energy also wind energy but solar energy
is a different level. I'm seeing huge
empty areas of land getting turn well
transforming into solar panel farms. You
know they are farming solar energy
especially here in the European Union.
It's it's insane. I mean they're closing
nuclear plants and they're trying to
replace all that energy with solar
energy. It's it's insane. So I do think
it's here to stay and for that you also
need copper. And as a third reason and I
don't like to speculate with these sad
things but let's be honest the war in
Ukraine should probably finish either in
that's why I believe or in 2027 the
longest. Okay. There is not much
progress going on there really. Um it
seems that there is not much point to
continue going with that war and
hopefully finishes over the next one to
two years which is really what I believe
will happen. right now for that you need
to try to understand that copper is
extremely important for the
infrastructure of any city and now if
they have to rebuild Ukraine all the
areas that have been affected I know
that for example KEF hasn't been the
capital hasn't been really affected but
all the east of Ukraine has been now you
need to try to understand that they need
to rebuild all that territory and for
that you need copper I mean you have
communication networks power grids,
wiring, plumbing, a lot of things that
copper needs needs to be used. Okay. And
for those four reasons, inflation
expectations are still high. So metals
are going to continue to go up. AI, you
need copper to build data centers to
continue developing AI,
solar panels, energy, and also I should
include here electric cars. You can see
that most car brands they are you know
already have electric cars and they are
uh pretty much focusing on the electric
cars part because there is a lot of
regulation also again especially in the
European Union and China about it and
also wars coming to an end and they need
to rebuild the infrastructure of those
countries and for that you need copper.
Okay. So for those four reasons, I do
believe that copper is set to continue
going higher over the next one to two
years in 2026 and 2027.
Possibly again if you see some kind of
retrace back here, I would imagine and I
would expect this area to act as
support. Okay. And from that I would
expect price to continue going higher to
around $18,000
the tone. Okay. That's around uh 40% up
from here. 50% off from here. Sorry. So,
that's what I'm expecting for copper.
I'm very bullish on copper. Now, how can
you buy copper? Well, there are many
ways to buy copper. The way I do it is
through ETFs. ETFs of mining companies.
Okay? Why? Because if I do think that
copper is a resource, a metal that is
going to be very demanded over the next
one to two years, you need to mine it.
Okay? So I do believe that investing in
ETF of miners
then that should be the the most trusted
way to invest in copper. So I'm
personally investing myself in COP X
that is the ETF of miners that I'm
putting my money in over the last two
years. Okay. But you also have of course
you know I COP COP M those are all ETFs
of miners. All right. So there are many
ways to do it. Many are many exchanges
and apps where you can invest money in
ETFs. You're going to need KYC for all
of them. But have a look where you can
invest in any of these three ETFs. I
would recommend you. Okay. Again, mine
is COP X, but you can do it in any of
them. And that's pretty much it, guys. I
hope that this video is useful that it
makes you think about it, makes you
consider
the advantages and the and the security
of investing in a safer asset than
Bitcoin. You know, that's diversifying
like copper and what could happen over
the next one to two years. Okay? So,
think about it. I'm not trying to push
you to invest into it. I'm only telling
you, of course, this is no financial
advice, but I'm only telling you what I
think that copper is bullish, what I've
invested myself in it, and what I do
think that it's going to continue to do
great over the next one to two years,
and why it's a good idea to diversify.
You know, you might have a crypto
portfolio and I tell you, yeah, crypto
is great, but it's risky, especially
alcoins.
I recommend you to also try to diversify
into real estate. That's what I'm doing.
And safer assets like metals, gold,
copper, silver, platinum. Okay, so I
hope I made you think about it, guys.
Thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you